do we cover not [ __ ] up because
i've seen a lot of guys uh out there
really just throw their entire life down
the toilet by [ __ ] up
they're they're on the path to make
millions i have
i have a good friend of mine um i have
not seen him in a while
um which actually reminds me i got to
reach out to him
um
who
ran a hyper growth company now when i
say hyper growth that that generally
means you go from zero
to
five to ten million dollars in like six
to twelve months like hyper growth fast
um let me get that off the screen before
i forget
and
when you get yourself in a position like
that and make bad choices that can be
critical he made one bad choice which
went critical and blew up the entire
[ __ ] uh
setup and some people got burned some
people lost money um i was an investor
luckily i got taken care of because i
positioned myself properly
but um
if you [ __ ] up things can change
dramatically
his his wife
immediately uh divorced him he just
finished building a massive custom home
um actually he wasn't building it it was
already framed and he was doing like a
full reno like a gut reno this thing was
i mean if you like big ass houses like
10 000 square foot cribs
um that's what we're talking about
um
three of his cars you know got
repossessed of course is uh one of his
kids won't even talk to him anymore just
do not [ __ ] up it's it's you know be
intelligent about taking risks i mean
people think that entrepreneurs and
super successful people take
big
stupid risks
and i don't think that's true i think
they take calculated intelligent
approaches and risks in life
um not all of them but a lot of them do
specifically in business with women
that's a different story i know a lot of
guys that have
given away half their wealth to a chick
and uh they should have seen it coming
and they could have prepared for it a
lot better but anyway
so there's the do not f it up part your
network is your net worth what time are
we at 20 minutes let's try to get get
through the rest of this real quick your
network is your net worth
i can't emphasize this enough you
stripped me of everything that i have my
house my cars all my money all my
investments take it all and leave me
with absolutely nothing
but my phone an internet connection
and my contact list on my phone okay
your network is your net worth
um it is the
you guys want a cheat code of life here
it is
have a good network have a very good
network surround yourself with
incredible people
the better you know and you know the
more of them the better of course
um i've said this many times you have to
be fastidious with your inner circle you
can't allow losers
um to
be one of the five most important people
in your life
you hang out with five broke fat dumb
losers that do nothing with their lives
you're gonna be the six i guarantee you
i guaran [ __ ] tia your network is
your net worth
okay do not argue this point pay
attention and make sure that you're
surrounding yourself with excellence
um
let's talk about
i've heard versions of this
people kind of butchered a little bit
and i've i've seen some terribly
some terrible looking dudes that are not
believable at all try to try to sell
this lyric to guys and call guys kings
stop calling yourselves kings unless
you're a king men
anyway
the lyrics are you will never lose women
chasing excellence but you will not
achieve excellence chasing women
okay listen to that again you will never
lose women chasing excellence but you
will not achieve excellence chasing
women
sounds straightforward
sometimes it's hard advice for people to
follow
let me uh
grab the link so what i'll do is
i'm gonna have you guys head over to
youtube
so
join in
and
ask live question
look at those super chats in a second
guys i've seen a few pop up while i'm
just typing this
uh so there's a stream yard link there
and i shall pin that to the top of the
live chat on youtube
and if you're not on youtube
why not
if you're watching this on other
platforms click that link i just dropped
and get your ass over to youtube and
when you do get over here hit the like
button i've got a thousand people
watching live and only like four and a
quarter
likes hit that like button guys help me
out with the algorithms all right
um
lucas
hamas
can you be a successful entrepreneur
while being an introvert
or having bad social skills in modern
age i'll be honest with you most
successful entrepreneurs
are manic they're introverted
some of them have personality disorders
you know
it takes it takes a little bit of crazy
i'm just being honest it takes a little
bit of crazy to say [ __ ] it i'm not
going to go take the sure thing i'm not
going to take the paycheck i'm not going
to go to the job
i am instead going to create my own
thing and i shall succeed
even though nine out of 10 businesses
fail
so yeah you have to you have to be a
little bit
not normal if i can put it that way so
being an introvert having bad social
skills
as long as you're not like totally
socially awkward you'll be just fine you
know welcome welcome to the
entrepreneurs club
how to join your social media club cost
uh you can
where are the banners do i have another
banner up here here it is yeah you can
join my community by going there
there is a cost
uh there's an intro video which shows
you what's all in it
if it's uh too expensive it's not for
you
um that's the level that we roll at in
the community
i don't know what it is i think it's
around a thousand bucks for the annual
fee
and you have access for the 12 months
but like i said you know um
your network is your net worth
join social media okay so where is the
last one billy said what do you think
about one man's business
versus businesses with employees so
you're talking about so that's a really
good question
you're talking about a company of one
okay there's a book out there called
company of one i'd like you guys to read
it
because it's a starting point
because you will start out for the most
part as a company of one
i've had a company of one it's basically
what i operate right now i don't have
any employees i have a couple of
contractors that do work for me
but they're not in payroll they're
remote and
works perfectly works fine for me
i've had employees i've had lots of
employees i've i've hired and fired
hundreds of employees in fact
um
over
i'm going to say
about 12 years or so that i worked in
corporate
um
my preference is company of one now if
i'm being honest
um employees are very expensive they're
not particularly efficient
uh they don't come into work they get
sick they get pregnant they take time
off they get injured
they fight with each other there's hr
issues they're banging each other
there's all kinds of stuff that comes up
with employees so
and with labor laws getting more and
more hostile towards business owners
my preference is company in one
figure out
how to make
location independent income so you can
work anywhere in the world if you have
to move you have that freedom and you're
not taking away your ability to earn
so that's a good question billy thanks
for throwing in here
devon
top three books that are mandatory reads
for entrepreneurs
if you go to the top pinned comment
of all my videos and here i'll do it
because i'm pretty sure i have some of
those books in there
stand by gentlemen
um okay
let's cover these books because i know
this i figured this was going to come up
i should have pulled this up to save the
time
okay where is it
pin top comment so if you go to here i'm
just going to put this up on the screen
share screen
i don't know this must be hard for you
guys to find for some reason so if you
go to any one of my videos this is like
a video from
last week
and at the top
pinned are a bunch of links so for my
books
if you want to book me for coaching over
here you see amazon books and products i
endorse for men
click that
and let's go to the books
what books would i recommend for
business
i got a lot of red pill reads in here
still
hooked is a very good book i would
recommend reading that
um
basically it explains how the human mind
works and follows habit-forming products
so if you're writing software
you definitely want to read this book if
you're going to start up a business
that's uh
involved with sas software as a service
you're
you know you've got some kind of
app going on that's a great book for
that think and grow rich is obviously
mandatory reading
uh the obstacle the is away is a great
book as well by ryan halliday um
he's got a lot of good great books
actually met the guy he's
very very smart for his age
i think he was in his 20s when i met him
actually but um this is about problem
solving you know and like i said earlier
one of the most important skills you
must have as an entrepreneur is problem
solving
economics in one lesson is a good one
just for general understanding of
finance by henry haslet
i would definitely
read
relentless by tim s grover and
more to the point of from an
entrepreneur i think one of the
probably best biographies would be
richard branson's losing my virginity
um read the everything store which is
about jeff bezos if you're into physical
products you know moving and shipping
stuff that's at a grand scale i mean
that's like really thinking big but it
gives you an idea of what that's all
about
and if you want to talk about um
learning about uh apparel
shoe dog is about nike
so those are all really good reads if it
comes to business for you
let's remove that from the screen do you
consider a clothing brand a serious
business also thank you for the
knowledge you share you're appreciated
you're welcome dude um
apparel can do quite well
it really can um
the i mean the problem with clothing
brands is you're moving a physical
product i'm not big on those
but clothing brands can be highly
profitable if you have a highly desired
brand that's made in a cheap location so
if you get
very cheap labor in indonesia or some
other place of the world where it costs
you next to nothing to make it and maybe
your cost per unit is five six seven
dollars but you're selling it for 50 100
200 i don't know
um i mean you're really pressing to get
into over 99 if you're buying something
for five bucks it's not going to be
super high quality but
take a look at it and make sure that
you've got margins
you've got to have somebody to sell it
to and this is where partnerships to
influencers can be highly profitable for
you um i'm actually surprised nobody's
come at me with a [ __ ] brand deal to
uh promote clothing because
i can't count the amount of times i've
seen people go where do you get that
shirt where do you get that jacket
that's a cool hat where do you get that
you know like where do you get your
glasses from all sorts of stuff
so smart guys that that have a clothing
brand should go looking for influencers
that they like and partner up with them
to help promote it
you